firefighters in california braved severe
weather conditions overnight to protect
the resort town of south lake tahoe from
the massive caldor fire now the wind has
died down just a bit but the fire is now
expanded to more than 320 square miles
officials say it is expected to grow
much larger before they can get it fully
under control
carter evans is in myers with more on
the story carter good morning to you
well good morning the good news now
those high winds have finally calmed
down but the fire is still burning in
we're less than 50 yards away from homes
that are heavily guarded by exhausted
firefighters who've been battling this
blaze for weeks with no clear end in
sight
the caldor fires pushing east toward the
nevada state line over terrain so dry
and dangerous officials say they may be
forced to let it burn for miles this is
some steep rugged nasty country and it's
just not safe in a lot of it to put our
firefighters up there in that stuff
many of the more than 4 200 firefighters
attacking this blaze have now been
working nonstop for 19 straight days
using everything from helicopter water
drops to bulldozers and hand tools
so far they've been able to keep the
flames away from south lake tahoe partly
by lighting backfires and clearing brush
to slow the fire's advance
the wind's picking up right now but this
fire is actually backing down the hill
and that's what firefighters want to see
a big concern though or dead trees like
this one if this were to catch fire it
could fall across the fire break they've
built endangering homes on the other
side as flames now approach the nevada
state line the threatened heavenly ski
resort is being transformed into a base
camp for firefighters there's a lot of
work to be done down here a lot of
threats still down here with these small
spot fires that are still burning down
here for battalion chief dave lochner
the battle is personal he's in danger of
losing his parents cabin fatigue has to
come into play you've been on this fire
since the beginning yeah there are days
where we're exhausted but that's the job
we're ready to go and we push through it
we're here till the end
one setback for firefighters this week
an entire strike team of 16 people was
sidelined because of a covet outbreak in
california now governor gavin newsom is
asking president biden for an emergency
declaration so they can get federal
assistance fighting this fire
vlad carter evans for us thank you